[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Hello, I'm Jen
Person for the "Developer
Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
The Android Dev Summit
happened last week
at the Computer History Museum
in Mountain View, California.
The team celebrated
10 years of Android
and shared updates to
Kotlin, Jetpack, Android
Studio, App Bundles, and of
course talked about Foldables.
For all the details and a
link to the session videos,
follow the link in
the description below.
Last week, the team introduced
both the AI Hub and Kubeflow
Pipelines to help make
AI simpler, faster,
and more useful.
AI Hub has plug
and play ML content
including pipelines, Jupyter
notebooks, TensorFlow modules,
and more.
Kubeflow Pipelines is a
new component of Kubeflow
that packages ML code
just like building an app,
so that it's reusable to other
users across an organization.
For more details on both,
head on over to the link.
Cloud Scheduler is a fully
managed cron job service
that allows any application
to invoke batch/big data,
and cloud infrastructure
operations-- essentially,
a modern managed cron service
for automated batch jobs.
And it's now available.
A link to the Quick
Start is on the post.
Containerd is an industry
standard container runtime
and Dockers core
runtime component.
It's now available in beta
on Containerd Optimized
OS for Kubernetes engine 1.11.
Example commands and a link to
the user guide are on the post.
The 2018 Go User survey
is open for responses
until November 30.
Please click through the post
to share your perspective
and help us create
the best programming
language that fits the needs and
desires of the people closest
to it.
That's you.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
the "Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Sometimes I'm walking around.
I'm like, why are
people staring at me?
And then I realize
it's because I'm
sort of dressed like a child.